hey guys what's up i'm so excited for
you to watch this interview before we
get into this interview i want to talk
about our sponsor
prime xbt if you're trading bitcoin
you got to be using primex bt not only
do they have global markets
available to anyone but they also have
great execution
low fees and an amazing user interface
the best part about primexpt is that you
can also follow some of the best traders
in the world
you go on you find someone who you think
is smart and you can literally just
follow their trades when they execute
something your portfolio executes the
same
and if you think you're one of the best
traders in the world then you can simply
go on there and have people follow you
and you earn a little extra income by
having those followers
so if you're trading bitcoin anywhere in
the world you got to use primex bt
they've won multiple awards for being
one of the best trading platforms
in crypto you can trade spot markets or
even use margin
so go on over to use primexpt you can go
to the description and click on the link
there
all right let's get into this episode
today i really hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got a
special treat for you today i've got
jesse here from variant thank you so
much for doing this
yeah thanks for having me i feel like
you have taken the world by storm but
before we get into what you're doing now
let's just go back in time and go
through your background
um where'd you grow up and how did you
get into investing
yeah so i grew up in new york um
went went to high school on long island
um went to college
in canada um i think relevant detail of
you know my early years was in high
school i got pretty involved with piracy
um much more than you know your average
teenager in their early 2000s
and thanks to a friend of mine i sort of
like found my way into this
community of people who are uploading
the files that everyone else was
downloading
and you know for me that was exciting
because i got access to the jz album
before everyone else
um you know i was burning copies of it
and and you know
selling them to my friends to pay for my
dsl modem and like
it was just amazing to have access to
all this content at a time when like
youtube didn't exist
you know facebook didn't exist there was
no soundcloud spotify et cetera
meanwhile here was literally every piece
of you know audio video
software video games etc on these
exclusive ftp servers
that were highly organized and
incentivized communities
not that similar from from the way
crypto communities function today
um and that was a formative experience
for me because it sort of
highlighted how media was going to
propagate on the internet
in the future in the very near future so
like four years later i'm in college
um wasn't the best of students was too
busy throwing parties and then
concerts um and and and then using
these new technology platforms that were
sort of coming up at that time
um to distribute media flyers music that
you know
of the artists that were performing at
these shows
and so i i'd say the straight line
through my careers i've always been
fascinated with how
media propagates online how the value of
that media is captured which
in the piracy era was was not happening
at all um
and then in the in the sort of platform
era started to get captured more and
more by platforms
um and what i set out to do
sort of after the my years in montreal
was set up an artist management company
to help artists
leverage these new tech platforms uh to
reach their fans directly
and capture more of the value for their
business you know
independent of the major label system
and so i worked with with a number of
big independent artists
um solange knowles blood orange magical
clouds
um to help them do this as much as
possible
and through that i became really um
sort of aware of the degree to which
these platforms were coming to dominate
the relationship between creators and
their audience
um and and also some some more you know
less glamorous
problems with the way royalties were
administered in in the traditional
music business and and then i learned
about bitcoin
in 2013 or so and that was you know the
turning point for me where
you know i read the white paper and and
to me the most interesting
thing was was not the financial side of
it though i thought that was cool and
still think it's really cool
um but the fact that you know bitcoin
was this peer-to-peer network that was
very similar in a lot of ways to the
peer-to-peer piracy protocols um
that i was you know engaging with as a
teenager and i was like this is kind of
you know kind of like bittorrent in a
lot of ways but it has something
that bittorrent lacked and that is um it
has this identity system
built into the protocol and that's you
know public private key cryptography
which is what
allows you to own your bitcoin and have
it be yours
independent of any third party and i
thought
that's really interesting what if you
could do the same for a different kind
of
digital asset instead of a you know a
financial asset what about a digital
media asset like an image of video or
song
if you could let the creator of that
asset be discovered through the asset
itself
they could capture much more of the
value without having to depend on the
platforms who intermediate that
relationship today
and so that idea was the spark for a
startup i co-founded in in 2014 called
media chain labs
where we set out to do that and i'll say
you know in hindsight we were we were
way too early i think today
a lot of those ideas are being realized
through nfts which we'll get into but
um so that's exciting but back then you
know bitcoin was
just coming into mainstream
consciousness it was it was too early to
be exploring non-financial use cases
um we had a good outcome in that we we
were acquired by spotify and i ended up
leading blockchain r d there to help
them
sort of think about and solve some of
the royalty administration problems that
were sort of adjacent to what we were
exploring
um and and then after spotify joined
andreessen horowitz um
and spent the better part of three years
on their crypto investment team
um before spinning out variant uh last
year so
i'll pause there that was that was a lot
you get major props from coming on here
and talking about jay-z right out of the
jump so uh
so kudos for that uh the other thing is
uh we're probably similar age
uh or at least ballpark wise and i
remember being
in uh in middle school or maybe even
into high school and uh
limewire was like you know really
popular but it was always like a russian
roulette you didn't know if you were
downloading a song or a virus and uh and
sometimes you got both
um so it always felt like your computer
you know drastically slowed down and i
think there's a whole generation of kids
who uh
who kind of grew up on a lot of those
platforms and uh
you know got a crash course in what uh
what's going on today in the world um
talk a little bit about variant and kind
of what your uh goal is i know that you
guys have this idea of kind of
um you know being a community oriented
fund that really wants to invest in
these community-owned
uh networks but like what exactly does
that mean yeah so
it's it's it's related to our thesis um
which which i call the ownership economy
thesis
and and so one lens to view what's
happening in crypto
is that for the very first time we have
networks that are you know worth
billions and billions of dollars that
are completely
built operated and owned by their users
right so with you know bitcoin of course
the first example
um there is no bitcoin company it's just
a permissionless network
your users or your listeners know this
really well
um and and and i think that model
that you know is at the core of success
the success of bitcoin
is being adapted to other networks in in
completely different
verticals and this is playing out um
you know from uh an audience of users
that's you know been fairly technical
you know developers were the first to
realize hey if i mine bitcoin
you know i can earn bitcoin and earn an
ownership stake in the network
um and so naturally developers and
technologists were the first to
understand that but increasingly
more and more some mainstream audiences
are realizing hey i can actually earn
some of the value i contribute to the
products and services i use every day so
you know there's bitcoin there's
ethereum um in d5 there's lots of
networks today that um that are owned by
their users you know a couple good
examples are
uni swap and compound which are both
financial marketplaces
uni i'll pick uni swap as an example
it's it's an exchange not unlike
coinbase but where
the users of the exchange are the ones
earning the transaction fees
uh in the marketplace in exchange for
putting liquidity into the marketplace
so so this ownership model um
is in my view the most market driven way
to build network effects
for you know for for next generation
platforms and it's what's driven
the really rapid growth in in bitcoin
and ethereum and the like
so what we're investing in at variant is
um
you know founders who are building
networks that have the objective
of becoming community owned because we
feel it's
it's these types of networks will grow
much faster and much larger
than their web 2 counterparts which are
largely owned by by vcs
and and that may sound counterintuitive
because we are a venture capital firm
right so how do you know how do we do
business well the the
i think the the strategy is you know
one of backing founders at the earliest
possible stage
um because building one of these
community-owned networks sort of
requires a
process that is you know i've referred
to as progressive decentralization
where you know you still have to build
something people want
people don't care to own something that
they don't want to use or
think is valuable and so you know
satoshi
put the white paper out then he had to
actually build or they had to build the
network right
someone has to do the work at the early
days and someone has to fund that work
right so that's where
variant fund steps in is to help
founders get ideas off the ground
um build a product that people want step
two is you know find users for that
product find product market fit
build a community and then step three
start to figure out how to you know
effectuate a distribution of ownership
to that community
such that they're incentivized to
continue to contribute and grow the
network alongside the founders
and and so that's what variant sort of
prides itself on doing
is helping founders get off the ground
build their community and then actively
participating in the networks that um
that we invest in got it and so when you
talk about these networks
maybe give us an example of something
you guys have invested in that you can
really kind of showcase what it means
uh from you know ideation of hey we
should go build this to where it is
today
yeah i think i think a really good
example is is compound
um so i i also mentioned uni swap
earlier i think they're another but i'll
i'll talk about compound here so
compound is a money marketplace it's
built on ethereum you know it enables
lenders and borrowers to find one
another and sort of you know
you know exchange digital assets through
a um
an automated uh process where you you
know if you're a lender you can lend
your stuff
out without having to you know interface
with the counterparty
um and as a borrower you you come in
fully collateralized
and are able to instantly borrow any
assets that are sort of on on the money
market
at a rate determined by available supply
and demand um
compound started i think late 2017 early
2018 the founder's name is robert lesner
um and and he had this you know this
vision for this marketplace
and raised an early round of funding
this is before variant existed
um but raised a small round of funding
built a team
built the product and um found some
early product market fit and that you
know they
they found lenders and borrowers and
they grew the sort of marketplace volume
um and the business model for this
marketplace is not
you know something new or unfamiliar
it's it's a rake on transactions that
are
you know happening through the
marketplace what's different about
um about compound is what happens with
that fee stream
and so um after you know
clear signs of product market fit and
and growth
compound said you know what this thing
is better if we get out of the way
and and turn ownership over to the
participants in the marketplace who are
driving the value of the thing and so
what they did is they launched um a
token a comp token
and they distribute it distributed it
directly to the users who are providing
liquidity to the money market so these
are the users that make the marketplace
valuable the ones that are driving the
fees
in in the marketplace and those users
were able to earn comp tokens
which in turn govern the the marketplace
itself
including governing what happens with
the fee stream
now comp is still a very early
you know early project today has over 10
billion
um in volume locked inside the money
market
so it's it's quite significant at this
point but like most startups you know
that fee stream is not being distributed
out to
shareholders it's being sort of
reinvested and in growth um
and and so that's a really good example
i think where distributing ownership
to the users of the product is a really
strong incentive to get them to actually
use the thing
and that's why compound has seen such
rapid growth over the last two years
going from
effectively zero to 10 billion in in
volume
so when you think about this locked
value i think there's a lot of people
who
either are new to crypto uh are coming
out of kind of the bitcoin world they
keep hearing uh especially in the
decentralized finance world like locked
value locked value
explain exactly what locked value is and
then why you think that's important
yeah so i'll i'll start by saying i
think locked value isn't actually the
best metric
for for d5 a lot of people refer to it
as like the the holy grail but the
reason it's a little misleading
is that locked value of crypto assets
changes
with the the value of those crypto
assets so in a market that's pretty
volatile where you know you have bitcoin
and eth going up at a rapid clip
it's not the best measure of growth in
these marketplaces because if bitcoin
fives x's
and you've got you know a million
dollars of of bitcoin in
in the wrap bitcoin in the compound
protocol you now have five million
without any new users putting more
capital in right so
tdl is a little bit misleading um but
what it refers to
is the value in the marketplace
um that is available to um to trade
with so in in the case of compound which
is a money marketplace it refers
specifically to the to the
amount of capital that one can borrow
from the money market in in the case of
uni swap
which is an exchange it refers to like
liquidity on the
the order book per se right so it's just
a measure of
like available liquidity in these
various financial marketplaces
i think um you know a better metric to
track
real growth is um to look at the number
of unique users and sort of the median
um you know contribution that they're
making
in terms in dollar amounts right so that
you don't want to look at like
um the the you don't want to like factor
in the volatility the dollar volatility
of the crypto asset you want to look
sorry i said dollar amounts i meant um
look at the crypto amounts in these uh
these marketplaces
and then the number of unique users that
are putting in um
you know whatever the median is got it
and so when people think through this
walk through maybe the
um relationship between like the comp
token right
with uh the usage in the system so if
there's no value that is being dispersed
out yet
to uh kind of these token holders what
is the
logic behind why the token would go up
down or stay you know kind of
stable in price and i think some people
uh
probably inaccurately think of it just
as like oh it's a stock
which you know maybe there's some
element of that but that's not kind of
the full story so just
describe a little bit how you think
about like the price of the token and
that's relationship with
uh the success or failure of any certain
project or community
yeah so i i think there's there's
definitely uh an apt parallel to stocks
in that
um you know shareholders govern court
the corporations that they own
um similarly you know token holders in
these community-owned networks govern
the network um
and and that's you know so that that's
the similarity i'd say
what's a little bit different is the
fact that tokens and shares don't have
the same sort of legal standing like
that you know
the the um there's a lot of sort of new
territory that needs to be explored and
built up in in the crypto space when it
comes to governance
and um now the the the
why would these things have value i
think that question is answered by
um you know one reason at the base class
is like there are a lot of developers
building on top
of these open protocols that have it's
important to keep in mind that you know
compound
runs on ethereum that means it can't be
shut off unless you shut off the whole
ethereum network
right so that gives developers
confidence
building on top of it because you know
developers have learned
the hard way that if you build on top of
closed networks like if you build on top
of facebook or
if you build on top of you know coinbase
or or
you know robin hood users learn the hard
way you if you use robinhood they can
just shut you off right so
what's different about a network like
compound is it runs on ethereum
that means it's running on machines all
over the world and even if one of those
machines is shut off
another one picks up the slack and the
system keeps going so developers have
confidence building on top
now they're only confident to the degree
that the underlying isn't going to get
yanked from underneath them and so one
of the reasons these comp tokens may
have value
is if a developer builds a valuable
service on top
with its own business model they may
want to have a say in how the underlying
is governed and and therefore the
governance
rights in and of themselves could be
valuable the other
reason that i think is a little further
out um is the idea that these
marketplaces do generate cash flows
right like compound is a money market
and there are
transaction fees in the market currently
those fees just accrue to a treasury
that's being you know reinvested in
growth
but at some point governance could
decide you know what this
fee stream should be distributed to the
user so it's a claim on those cash flows
and that's the
where this you know the stock connection
i think is most app
got it and so what do you think is like
the downside in terms of uh it's very
obvious
why uh community owned networks would be
valuable for the users
um it's also pretty obvious why through
financial incentives you could really
bootstrap
uh kind of the the network effect what's
the downside to shifting to this
decentralized version of some of these
products or services
well i think the the the most uh the
foremost one is
um it's really hot hard to do you know
to design
a product that people want by committee
right you know the best startups have
strong
sort of leadership strong product vision
and they iterate quickly they move
quickly
um you know once once they're in the
public markets as a traditional company
you know you're beholden
to shareholders and what they want and
um you know that that can pull you in a
number of directions it can slow you
down it can
force you to optimize for short-term
profits over long-term
growth and um and so i think that's
that's one of the potential downsides
that founders need to think about
when they're going through this process
of progressive decentralization
and turning over ownership to users you
don't want to do it too
soon that's what happened in 2017 when
there were all these icos they
kind of had the right idea where they're
like you know we should give our users
ownership and then they'll be
incentivized to try our thing the
problem was they hadn't built the thing
yet and so they got you know hamstrung
by having to build a product by
community consensus as opposed to having
a founder sort of drive the initial
product vision
build the thing and then effectuate
distribution to the actual users once
they already
are using the product so i think that's
that's one downside i think
another is that um you know
products do need to continue to evolve
so this is just an extension of
the prior point once you're community
owned you your decision-making process
is beholden to governance right and and
so how do you remain competitive
i think uh a good sort of lesson the
founders can look to is
um you know visa actually started as a
cooperative
and um that you know a bunch of banks
came together pooled money
built this network and and grew the
network effects of
of the of the payment system really
quickly because they all had skin in the
game to do so
um but as as it grew and competition got
more fierce you know mastercard came in
american express
these are converted from a cooperative
to a for-profit entity
because they could raise more capital
through that structure
and ultimately you know that's what they
felt they needed to do in order to
remain competitive
versus the others who had raised
considerable amounts and we're moving
quickly
so i think that's something to just keep
in mind is that um you need to remain
nimble
even once in the public markets even
with user ownership in order to remain
competitive
i'm optimistic that because crypto
tokens
allow you to distribute value very
granularly and program
programmably so like in an automated
fashion we'll be able to you know to
make
cooperatives a lot more efficient you
know like a lot more automated than
they've been in the past and that's a
lot more competitive so i think this
market can you know this market
structure can scale
what do you think about the difference
between equity and tokens as you deploy
capital right so you mentioned that your
venture capital fund
and i'll kind of put that in air quotes
because i think people think generally
like hey you go buy
equity you guys are buying tokens uh one
are you buying equity as well and then
two how do you think about
uh if faced with hey i could buy equity
or a token uh
is there a framework or like a pros and
cons that you think through as to what
you would rather own
yeah totally so so i think there there
is a sort of best practice funding
structure in the space and i think this
is something that
the folks at a16z have worked on a lot
and a lot of the deals
i worked on there were structured this
way similarly at variant most of the
deals we do are structured as
equity with a warrant for tokens
and and so there's really two separate
components here
the reason you know so i'll start by
saying a lot of the
companies that we invest in they do have
a very specific goal which is to become
a decentralized network coordinated by a
token
just like bitcoin and ethereum and so on
um
so the expectation is that a lot of the
value of what's being built
will ultimately accrue to the token um
but in the short term
the reason you know we're buying equity
is that equity
allows for it's the most flexible
instrument for aligning incentives
between investors and entrepreneurs
and you know at the earliest stages of a
company flexibility
is is paramount because things change
you know like founders need to
have be able to pivot if they if the
idea or the market moves in a direction
they weren't anticipating
and so equity alliance investors with
the founders should they decide hey
you know that network we said we were
going to build it doesn't make sense in
the market today
we're doing something different equity
preserves the alignment
the the the pro in 2017 a lot of
investors were buying um
safs which were a promise for tokens in
the future
the the problem or you know that can
occur with that
structure is a team is sort of
committing in advance to say we're
building a network
with this specific token and
maybe that doesn't make sense as the
market evolves right so
it doesn't allow for the the flexibility
that that's important to early stage
startups
so so that's why we do equity and then
the warrant for tokens essentially what
it says is
if you do end up building a network that
is coordinated by a token
at the time you launch the network
hopefully that network is sufficiently
decentralized
so that the token is no longer a
security and at that point
this warrant gets exercised um and the
investors get their sort of
you know pro rata share of the tokens in
alignment with
with uh the founders um and the critical
thing there is that
the the network does need to be
sufficiently decentralized at that point
which typically means that a lot of the
tokens aren't just going to founders and
investors but are also going to the
actual users
who are operating the network on a go
forward basis
big sub makes a lot of sense i want to
switch gears and talk about what seems
to be like the topic
uh du jour which is uh nfts non-fungible
tokens
uh last year i think it was september uh
i wrote this thing publicly just saying
hey look i think digital art is gonna be
bigger than traditional art
um it's very similar to kind of bitcoin
versus gold
uh the digital version is gonna be
bigger than the analog version
that may seem crazy today but like you
know see in 20 years and we'll see what
happens type situation
uh as you can imagine literally got
laughed out of the room
fast forward to today and i'm actually
even thinking to myself well wait a
second like maybe i was uh archaic am i
thinking of just comparing digital art
to traditional art because it seems like
nfts are taking on a life of its own
there's all these different
implementations like it's much much
bigger
than just digital art so what is your
kind of
um you know thought process maybe at a
high level just like when you think of
nfts today
why do you think that it's interesting
or valuable
yeah so i think i think of nft is sort
of
um you know through the the lens of the
ownership economy thesis right so
again the idea that um you know in the
future the next
big products on the internet are going
to be built operated and owned by the
users
and you know when you think about media
on the internet today
you know every day billions of images
videos songs are shared on social media
platforms
what's interesting about what's actually
happening there is is
you know creators of those media files
they're essentially uploading the files
to facebook to twitter to
to instagram and what's happening is
they're copying and pasting the file
from their computer to the servers of
those companies and along with the file
they also copy and paste ownership of
the file itself and that that's because
somewhere along the way in the terms of
service
you know you agreed when i upload stuff
you guys can monetize it how you see fit
right um so that's what's allowed the
the platforms
that are dominant today to capture so
much of the value that their users
create
um what's different about nfts is it
sort of inverts the ownership model of
media where
it allows creators to own their media in
the same way they can own a bitcoin you
can now own like a digital media asset
in the same way you own a digital
currency asset and that is directly
without any third party
in between and so as a result creators
are going to start to
capture much more value directly by you
know people buying
their work and and so you know i think
the reason why you gravitated towards
digital art is it's the most obvious
um example it functions sort of similar
to the way the traditional art market
works
but that's just never been possible on
the internet to date where everyone
rents
access to spotify rents access to you
know
um to patreon now you're actually able
to own
content from the creators that you like
and that's
that's kind of important because it
aligns incentives between creators and
collectors where
you know if you actually own a
collector's work or our creators work
you're kind of incentivized to help them
grow their profile you want to see them
succeed
because that has direct you know
consequences for for the value of the
work that you own
which you know you can later resell so i
i sort of refer to this
as this concept as patronage plus
where you know in in the internet to
date
you've been able to patronize creators
and you know pay them a monthly
subscription
on sub stack or patreon um but you've
not been able to actually realize
any financial benefit from doing so and
it's not not the case that everyone is
in it to make money but it's certainly a
you know the prospect of being able to
profit
from patronizing a an artist is a strong
incentive to to become a patron in the
first place and that's why i think this
you know
we're going to start seeing this market
grow really really quickly
because um it aligns incentives between
creators and their audience
in a better way than web 2 platforms
have been able to and
and beyond art i think you know this
medium opens up to
every piece of of media on the internet
you know it's
it's um it's memes it's uh it's digital
assets for games
it's collectibles like you know nba top
shot i used to collect basketball cards
as a kid so
the fact that these are digital is is
amazing and that means you can do
more with them right so critical thing
is
unlike paintings unlike basketball cards
or like you know toy figures
these are programmable assets and
they're assets that
live on open blockchains that anyone can
program so
just like anyone can build on top of the
bitcoin network
anyone can build on top of an nft on an
open blockchain and give it
more utility right so a developer
can build an application that where i
can bring my digital art to it
and display it or i can bring my game
asset from game to game
and have it function in different ways
that make it more valuable
so today the baseline is i collect this
stuff because
i like it i think it's interesting i
think it's valuable i might be able to
resell it for more
tomorrow it's i collect this stuff
because it's mine
and developers are building stuff to
make it more util you know have more
utility and
and you know more interesting and so
developers are going to have to start
catering
to users and creators to get them to
mint stuff and
bring their stuff to the platform as
opposed to platforms today locking your
stuff
in for them to monetize and i think
that's you know that inversion is is
pretty powerful
so let's start with kind of uh the
equivalent of digital art right kind of
the easiest thing for people to wrap
their head around
uh when i first saw this it was very
obvious like one to program ability so
i can have sound i can have motion i can
like do all these things that you can't
do with just a painting right
uh the other piece was from like a user
experience standpoint so i can like
take it with me virtually right i don't
have to physically carry the painting
around like very very simple stuff
uh when i display it i can literally
have that picture on the wall rather
than it be static and the only way to
change is to literally take it down and
put another one
i can have it change by the hour by the
season by the lighting in the room like
there's all these things that you can do
with the display of it
um and kind of have the the variation
but
what really started to fascinate me was
if you look at the traditional art
market with like a sotheby's or
something they bring all these people
together for these auctions
now what you can basically do is take a
digital file you can literally auction
it off to anyone in the world and you
can send it to them almost immediately
and just like an open decentralized
protocol like bitcoin or ethereum allows
people to
access financial services as long as
they have an internet connection
it felt like it was going to democratize
or really break down a lot of walls to
quote
the art market right but i think your
point of like okay that's like step one
that's the easiest thing to wrap your
head around
maybe give us an example of like what's
the furthest out
from that that you've seen with nfts
like in terms of an implementation of
the technology
where you're like this kind of gives you
a peek around the corner as to what
somebody may be able to do in the future
um and they're kind of just touching on
it now
yeah there's there's so much on it the
space is moving so quickly so
i'll i'll give it i feel like i'm
talking to the experts so come on
yeah i'll give you i'll give you a few
different examples so
one is on the on the financial side of
things i think there's
you know that's your point in the
traditional art world you know there's a
lot of gatekeepers there's galleries
right there's there's auction houses
um and there's there's a lot of insiders
who have
all the information today right um in
you know the internet blows those kinds
of institutions wide open
it's no different for for art what
you're starting to see
is all kinds of like different financial
marketplaces emerge
for these assets and again these are
marketplaces that allow the creators and
the collectors to capture more of the
value
for example really base case um example
is
it is possible to specify in an nft when
when the creator mints it
that they should get a royalty in
perpetuity whenever it's resold
so that that is a very basic thing that
you can do with programmable r today
that you you know
you can't do with legacy or um or you
could but it'd be really hard to track
down all those secondary sales and
and get the payments that you're you're
owed right so that's
very easy to automate and programmable
and happening right now
um i think you know another financial
example
is there's people packaging up these um
these these digital art objects into
indices
and so like if you're not you know if
you want exposure to digital art but you
don't you're not a
expert curator yourself well you can
rely on someone else who is
and easily invest in in an index and so
play that out like 10 years right we're
gonna have
um all kinds of financial marketplaces
around all kinds of creative work
that just didn't make sense in the
legacy world because it was too
cumbersome too you know
um fragmented to to to invest in so
that's the finance side i think on the
on the more creative side of things
um today there's lots of you know game
developers building
um building cool games that are sort of
crypto native and
you know to be fair the the big game
companies haven't caught on to this yet
um and a lot of the games as a result
are sort of like janky they're
they're kind of fun for uh for people
who are way down the rabbit hole but
they show a promise which is
today you can bring your game asset from
one game to another
you can't do that with fortnite skins
you know they lock you in you buy your
skins
you might sell them in a sketchy way on
a secondary marketplace
but then fortnite doesn't see any of the
benefit of that um
so the cool thing about these these
crypto native game assets
is they're portable and developers can
bring
new meaning to them by programming new
experiences on top there's lots of
you know lots of examples of people
buying a game asset then bringing it to
a virtual world where they hang out with
friends and they sort of you know put it
on display
and so in a world where you know ar and
vr are more common in our daily lives
like
you're going to see a lot more of this
and users are going to come to demand
that portability that comes from to true
digital ownership
and further developers that the big game
studios are going to realize
we can actually make more money by
leaning into this because again we can
capture
a portion of the resale value that's
happening in sketchy ways outside of our
platform today
um i think bottom line the way i'd sum
it all up is you know free market
economies
are the best engine of growth we don't
have free market economies in the
digital world today
because we live inside of you know these
big platforms we live inside of you know
facebook or in the case of gaming
fortnite
what blockchains bring to the table is a
is a sort of property right system that
functions
more like the traditional you know
physical world or you know countries
that have strong property rights anyway
um and it brings that to the digital
world and i think that's going to be an
engine of
of growth unlike anything we've seen in
the internet to date
yeah what what is when you think through
this um
where does the like platforms that end
up being
valuable is it the artist ends up being
kind of the uh
the most valuable component is it the
platform that helps to mint
uh the nfts is it the exchanges is this
all centralized infrastructure is it
decentralized infrastructure
like i think people are very focused on
if you take like top shot uh
as an example right you've got a
centralized entity that's actually
creating these in partnership they've
done a licensing deal for
intellectual property like it feels very
similar to
you know what disney would do right or
or some other centralized entity
but then the actual end product is a
completely different thing right in
terms of this nft
um and kind of the the interest and the
digitization that we're seeing there so
how do you see centralization
decentralization and where do you see
value accruing kind of in the overall
ecosystem
yeah it's a great question and and you
know to be honest i've got some ideas
they're early ideas it's it's not
totally crystal clear yet but
i'll give my early thoughts so i think
um you know what's captured value
in in the you know crypto space today is
you know
blockchains themselves that are the
property rights systems right like
bitcoin ethereum
most valuable networks so i think the
the blockchains where these assets are
issued
will continue to benefit from increased
you know prop
property being issued and tracked on the
chain um
another area that's that's captured a
lot of value encrypted to date
independent of nfts are wallets things
like you know coinbase
um and and you know hardware wallets and
the like the places where people store
the value that lives on the blockchain
so i think wallets may end up having
um an important role to play with nfts
too because
you know they solve the problem of hey
where's my stuff well it's you know it's
in my wallet and that's where you go to
view your nfts maybe it's where you go
to trade them
and maybe there's a good business model
there just being close to the end user
so that's a more traditional one i think
some new areas that are that are
net new to nfts are um are
are dows or you know collectively owned
groups
that curate these items right so in in a
world where every image every video
every song
is you know issued as an nft
um it then becomes a question of what is
valuable
and you know that's the role that
galleries play in the art market is sort
of filtering through the noise and
creating the context
um that makes these assets valuable and
i think we'll see a similar kind of
curatorial layer emerge in the nft world
but instead of it being you know
sotheby's or
um or christie's that are sort of
gatekeeping what isn't isn't valuable
you'll have um groups of people you know
like subreddits
uh coming together to say we want to
collectively pool
value on the internet and buy that thing
because we think it's valuable
and and so one way to um you know to
access the value in this space maybe to
not access directly but access through
an index
that is curated by you know by this
community of people online who have
a specific view and by the way i think
you can extrapolate that out to all
investing
in this space not just nft investing it
may be the case that you know variant
fund
three is not a venture fund run by me
but but something that is actually
community owned
if the sec would let us do that um so
so those are some early ideas i think um
just maybe maybe one last one in in
where where nfts will capture value i
mean i i didn't mention it specifically
but it's the assets themselves right and
and that's you know that's the content
is king
that's remain kind of true um you know
in spite of the internet if if you make
something that's
that people love and and want to own you
know
you can capture value that way so for
creators you know that's i think that's
the big upside
um of this model that doesn't exist in
web 2 today
i'm cheering for you i hope you figure
out how to do fun three as
a as a community organization that'd be
awesome
uh before we get into the rapid fire
questions to end this uh
last thing i want to talk about it's
kind of social money and uh
it's something that when you said
earlier about like the idea of creators
launching these nfts and and value
almost accruing as
uh a creator or an individual becomes
you know more popular more valuable
however you want to kind of measure it
uh it feels like there's some uh
movement in this social money space it
hasn't really kind of taken off it
hasn't reached kind of any level of
mainstream adoption from what i've take
uh from what i've noticed but like what
are your thoughts there and is that
something that would be competitive
uh kind of with nft is that a
complimentary thing is it
binary like hey one of them wins one of
them doesn't just how do you kind of
uh view social money in comparison to
everything else we've talked about today
yeah yeah so so maybe i'll start out
with a definition because i think it
means
different things to different people so
the way i think about social money is
it's it's it's a person sort of issuing
a token
um that represents you know themselves
right so like
pompcoin would be would be an example of
social money now the question is what is
the value
of and and then it's you know i think
it's whatever
value you give to it right maybe it's
access to
spend an hour with you cost 10 popcorn
or something like that
um so it's it's a really interesting
idea
that i i think is there's a lot of
fertile ground for experimentation there
right because like
there's again it's all about aligning
incentives between creators
and and their audience um that's what
nfts do
you know you buy you buy something from
a creator now you own it you can resell
it if their profile grows
at a profit right so the alignment of
incentives is what's driving the growth
in this ecosystem
social tokens offer that same promise
the question
that i think is still open-ended for for
a lot of projects that are experimenting
here
is what is uniquely enabled by owning
social money
like what does the token actually unlock
in terms of
you know an interaction or or value
um and and so we haven't seen anyone
quite nail
it yet some folks are saying it should
be a financial relationship like kind of
similar to the the concept of an isa an
income sharing agreement where
essentially i'm backing you as a creator
i get a cut of all your revenue streams
so not unlike a a record deal or
you know a a you know sports contract or
something like that right
um but you know that has lots of
you know implications that are legal and
um
and and so we haven't seen a ton of
experimentation on the financial side
other folks come at it from um more the
angle of like
it's the new fan club right like you
used to buy you used to buy a membership
to an artist fan club it would get you
merch it would get you access to you
know backstage at the show
and social money is the way to do that
it's just a fan club with a with a
floating market price
which again gives you that incentive
alignment um that makes your fans into
super fans
um i don't think it's this idea is
mutually exclusive with the concept of
nfts
in fact i think it's quite complimentary
like you could imagine
that um owners of of your social money
get first
dibs to buy a you know an nft that you
issue or
the other way around holders of your nft
are given some social money um you know
because they're already
your biggest fans they bought your work
right and then they get access to
whatever the social tokens enable
so i think we will see the confluence of
these two things come together
but the reason i think nfts are having
their moment first
is that the interaction model between
creator and audience is is
well understood i'm buying your work
that's something that we understand
really well
whereas the social money interactions
are sort of new and unfamiliar and so
they there's got to be a lot more
experiments run before something catches
yeah makes sense is there any area um of
kind of this community on networks
or nfts where you're like hey no one's
talking about this yet but a year from
now that's going to be the
thing everyone's paying attention to
almost like the most underestimated
aspect
yeah i mean i think i think we haven't
really explored
um the what i call composability of nfts
which is an idea we've touched on
um you know in the conversation thus far
it's this idea that
these assets are portable and you can
bring them um
with you to new contacts i think that's
that's um
we're in the sort of early eruption you
know phase of
of the the hype cycle where um it's all
about
getting into the market speculating
buying and the prices of these assets
are going crazy
crypto punks which is sort of the first
crypto collectible nfts issued on
ethereum back in 2017
they're they're selling for like
millions of dollars right now um
so we're in this frenzy phase inevitably
there's going to be a cool off period
and like any market cycle and
during that cool off period i think is
when you're going to start to see
developers
go back to the drawing board and be like
what can we do that's net new and that
that's when i think you're going to
start to see the the
composability of these assets really
emerge where developers start to say hey
those crypto punks
we just built this new experience on top
of them and i think that will dominate
the conversation going forward
it's it's who's building the coolest
experience around
nfts to give these assets more value
more meaning and drive
the next cycle um down the line
yeah that's really really fascinating um
i got three questions to you
uh and you'll get to ask me one to
finish up uh first question what's the
most important book that you've ever
read
interesting so i'm going to go with
protocol
um so this is a this is a book about how
control
exists in the internet era in spite of
the fact that the protocols
are all open and i think it's it's an
instructive read for anyone
building in the crypto space today given
everyone's you know values are about
decentralization and
permissionlessness um it's instructive
how
the same ideals were present in the web
one movement and we didn't quite get
there
uh in web two and so for for people
building in web three i think it's a
it's a really important read
um to make sure we get it right this
time i have not read that i'm gonna read
that one this weekend
that's a fantastic suggestion uh second
one comes from our friends over at eight
sleep uh i sleep eight hours or uh six
hours a night was absolutely demolishing
my body
uh in crypto 24 7 365 market doesn't
help
uh but now i've been sleeping on their
thermoregulated bed
and uh it's fantastic sleep really cold
and get eight nine hours and feel
amazing
what's your sleep schedule and how has
that changed over time
it's not i'll tell you it's not good um
and that's
it's for all the reasons you mentioned
uh especially right now in
the nft hype cycle so i mean i i
definitely strive to get eight hours
i've been doing far less today
um you know i'm working on it is what
i'll say
it's uh uh there's much people i know
that recently left finance that have
gone into crypto and some are trading
some radio doing whatever
uh and they're just like you don't
realize how nice it is to have hours of
operations as a human
right the machines they don't care but
uh from humans like when the market
closes
everyone takes a deep breath here that
none of that happens right
yeah and the space is just moving so
fast that you know
i think unfortunately it's it's only
humans that can keep up with all the new
ideas
to you know to write them the programs
that machines run to keep up with the
market
absolutely uh last question for you is
uh aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
you know i i'd say i would put myself in
the believer camp it just seems
it's too big out there for for for there
not to be anything else out there
yeah i'm in the uh they're probably out
there
and they just being some sort of
intelligent life form but probably too
far away will never come in contact
unfortunately and so
uh you know it's a fun uh intellectual
exercise but uh but probably a worthless
one
in terms of preparing for them or
anything like that right
um what uh what one question you have
for me to finish up
i guess i'm curious what what um what's
your taste in digital art what do you
look for in in
assets you collect uh so i read this
book uh boom
uh which couple guys sent me and
basically goes back and looks at the
like uh
legacy art world and just kind of the
history of it through kind of the 20th
century
um and uh yeah i guess 20th century and
really what you find out is like it's
all stories
right like what makes a van gogh more
expensive or valuable than something
else like
it is the story and so uh you got to be
careful because that's like the fine
line between like
the charlatans of the world and then
actually like the true value in the
world
um but when you start to understand like
the market structure and how important
the auction houses were
uh it's actually picking winners in in
the art world uh i think we're gonna see
kind of a recreation of that
i actually don't think it's gonna be
auction houses like it'll be some other
form of that
um but ultimately when i look at art i'm
in the camp of like i couldn't tell you
what's good art and bad art if you
showed me five pieces in the legacy
worlds like which one's the most
expensive
i just don't know right i don't have
that eye i don't i don't have kind of
that um
that artistic uh inclination and so
instead what i
think of it as is it's much more like a
startup right is if you kind of look at
it and you say hey
what is the story behind this what is
kind of that directional arrow of
progress like the equivalent of that for
the art world
um that's basically the decisions that i
make uh and then the other piece of it
too i think
is um that there's this idea and uh
startups of like things in motion stay
in motion and so when you see kind of
momentum like you should go pay
attention
uh i think the same thing happens with
artists right so when you see an artist
start to sell a couple of pieces
and it's very obvious like hey this
artist is gaining more and more
um traction traction is really a sign
for the community it's really for
audience right like you're basically
increasing the demand side of the
equation and so if you have you know
relatively fixed supply
from an artist and you've got an
increasing demand for that artist like
obviously
uh if you're just looking at as a pure
financial investment like the price of
those assets are going to go up over
time
and so i just kind of you know chalk it
up and say look i'm figuring out
alongside everybody else but that's you
know a couple of the frameworks that
i've been using
yeah that makes sense and i think i
think it speaks to something important
about
crypto markets art market traditional
art markets and digital art markets
they're all reflexive markets right so
you know
you know it's better than anyone but the
the more that sort of insiders talk
about the value of the thing
and the more value they trade in in
internal to one one another
the more outsiders look at that and say
oh look at all that value those guys are
crazy
what's going on the more they pay
attention and then that's what pulls the
outsiders in and so these reflexive
markets just compound
and that's what drives activity in in
the space i
i couldn't agree more where can we send
people to find you on the internet or
find out more about the work you're
doing at variant
it's just variant dot fund
simple you you uh you are a man of very
little uh
little words on that one so variant.fund
uh jesse listen thank you so much for
doing this i think people are really
really gonna learn a lot from this and
you guys are on the cutting edge a lot
that's going on in this industry
uh so congrats on all the success and uh
just keep going watch this again in the
future
cool thanks so much for having me it was
fun